[Musique]
et c'est général Patrick du tartre
bonjour général de l'armée de l'air
merci d'être à nos côtés depuis qu'elle
en réclame l'Ukraine n'est jamais
apparue en meilleure posture de pouvoir
enfin obtenir
ces chars de combat de fabrication
occidentale déjà j'aimerais avoir votre
réaction à vous alors combien de
commenter ce changement à la tête du
ministère de la défense allemande on
sait que tous ont les yeux rivés vers
Berlin aujourd'hui a commencé par par
les Ukrainiens
oui vous avez tout à fait raison et
comme la signaler votre correspondante à
Berlin le point clé ça va être la
réunion de Rammstein ce vendredi 20
janvier pourquoi parce que ça va être la
troisième réunion des alliés pour
déterminer si vous voulez une position
occidentale ou européenne commune face
donc à l'invasion russe en Ukraine et
pour répondre dans une certaine mesure à
la demande pressante du président
elenski pour disposer de moyens disons
plus modernes et plus lourd en fait et
c'est moyen plus lourds effectivement ce
sont les chars de combat c'est la France
qui a donné le temps finalement au début
janvier lorsque le président Macron a
décidé d'autoriser l'envoi du trentaine
de mx-10 RC c'est que c'est un char
relativement léger extrêmement mobile
c'est un peu une sorte de cavalerie
légère et dans la foulée d'ailleurs les
Allemands ont décidé également d'envoyer
des mardeurs qui sont aussi de ce qui
sont des blindés moins lourds mais qui
permettent si vous voulez de protéger
l'infanterie même chose pour les
Américains avec des Bradley les
Allemands avaient déjà envoyé une époque
des premiers chars qu'on appelle des
gépards qui sont des petits chars mais
qui sont qui étaient surtout utilisés
pour la défense solaire là le la
nouvelle annonce britannique d'envoyer
des challenger 2 là c'est des charges
encore plus lourds si vous voulez c'est
assez modeste c'est une petite quinzaine
14 je crois qu'ils sont qui ont été
annoncés et cela si vous voulez ils ont
surtout un canon de 120 mm et c'est des
charges assez lourds qui sont capables
en tout cas de se poser de manière
frontale aux chats russe et peut-être
d'enclencher une contre-offensive
lorsque le moment sera venu voilà on
voit un moment où vous parliez toutes
ces promesses qui ont été formulées par
les Occidentaux effectivement ces
dernières semaines France Allemagne
États-Unis suivi du Royaume-Uni avec ses
14 chars challenger 2 la Pologne aussi
et là et la Finlande on le sait ce sont
des prêtres à livrer des léopards
allemands mais elle requiert d'abord de
la valve de Berlin expliquez-nous
peut-être c'est cette notion qu'on
comprend peut-être pas nous le char de
fabrication allemande et donc c'est
Berlin qui doit autoriser les autres
pays à livrer cet armement à l'Ukraine
oui parce que ce sont eux c'est en fait
c'est une c'est une convention qui
existe entre le constructeur enfin ou en
tout cas le pays qui fabrique ces
Charlots ce sont donc les Allemands et
la particularité du char challenger 2
c'est qu'elle n'a presque 2000 en Europe
et en fait c'est effectivement c'est un
char qui est extrêmement bien adapté si
vous voulez à la problématique crânienne
pour résister à l'invasion russe
pourquoi parce qu'elle va donner une
partie de mobilité et puis surtout de un
moment extrêmement fort
occidental de grande précision
relativement très bien protégées donc et
le déclencheur c'est l'autorisation
allemande parce que ce sont eux qui
fabriquent ces chats alors il y a
plusieurs pays qui ont proposé
effectivement de délivrer ces armements
je pense que la réunion de Ramstein doit
ce sens va être décisive parce que c'est
elle qui va décider ou non si vous
voulez de de d'ouvrir ce verrou en fait
allemand enfin disons qu'il il
souhaitait s'engager avec une grande
prudence comme depuis le début de
de ce conflit même s'ils ont envoyé
beaucoup de
d'armement le léopard c'est léopard II
notamment c'est un Lambron significatif
et c'est vrai que ce serait un moment
adapté aux besoins Ukrainiens
aujourd'hui en juin dernier l'Ukraine
avait failli arriver à ses fins on se
souvient que l'Espagne avait formulé une
promesse de livraison puis elle avait
fait marche arrière est-ce qu'on risque
à nouveau de voir le phénomène se
répéter on sait que les Occidentaux
redoutent de se voir entraîner embarquer
dans ce conflit
oui vous êtes tout à fait raison c'est
ce qui explique d'ailleurs la prudence
allemande qui est historique et
notamment même vis-à-vis de leur armée
vous souvenez que de juste après le
début du conflit
l'Allemagne a décidé de de se réarmer en
fait et et d'affecter un budget
extrêmement important puisqu'on parle de
200 milliards de dollars même si
aujourd'hui assez peu une petite partie
qui était enclenchée
je pense qu'on est aujourd'hui
malheureusement mais en tout cas c'est
comme ça dans une dynamique
d'affrontement assez importante et au
niveau du conflit de la guerre qu'il y a
entre entre que subit bien sûr l'Ukraine
avec l'invasion russe et donc
à mon sens assez probable que ce verrou
saute et que
dès le vendredi 20 janvier on décide
effectivement d'envoyer des armements de
type léopard 2 qui serait
qui sont une psychologie extrêmement
fortes dans la guerre une nouvelle étape
décisive dans la guerre on comprend bien
d'ailleurs on voit que les Russ
es
redoutent finalement ce glissement
puisque Kremlin a juré hier je le cite
de brûler les chars livrés à l'Ukraine
par par l'Occident c'est une posture ça
c'est les signes d'inquiétude des Russes
oui vous avez tout à fait raison tout à
fait raison et je pense qu'on est dans
une dynamique positive côté ukrainienne
et côté occidental c'est surtout de
montrer de la détermination de
l'Occident à
être aux côtés de l'Ukraine pour cette
guerre qui est totalement injuste et qui
devrait d'ailleurs se régler sur le plan
diplomatique je regrette à
personnellement que
que l'ONU ne s'engage pas suffisamment
dossier de trouver une une solution
pacifique à ce à ce conflit mais pour
l'instant ce qu'on observe c'est que
c'est un
affrontement extrêmement fort et c'est
vrai que cette livraison d'armes
notamment à partir de léopard II à
partir de j'espère une décision positive
dans ce cadre-là par les Allemands va
être un point important vous parlez de
décision décisive dans ce conflit ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'avec
cette équipement l'Ukraine serait
peut-être en mesure de s'imposer enfin
on va bientôt célébrer le premier
anniversaire du début de l'invasion
russe en tout cas les données les moyens
de stopper toutes velléité
d'agressions supplémentaires au niveau
du territoire
ukrainien et les moyens aussi de
contre-attaquer c'est surtout ça qui va
être important et donc peut-être que ça
amènera si vous voulez
déjà autour de la table c'est à dire en
tout cas une réflexion du président
Poutine pour se dire que maintenant ça
suffit et qu'il faut trouver une
solution pacifique à ce conflit un
dernier mot
alloué à l'Ukraine l'aide militaire
octroyer au 1er juin 2022 en millions
d'euros vous avez peut-être voir ces
chiffres je vous les commenter en
première position évidemment les les
États-Unis suivi avec quatre millions
200000 euros suivi par l'Allemagne la
Pologne le Royaume-Uni le Canada
l'Australie qui arrive en 8e position
11e position la Suède 12e position la
France ça c'était l'état des lieux au
1er juin 2022 on sait que les choses
peuvent très vite tourner à l'avantage
ou au désavantage des Ukrainiens on sait
notamment qu'il y a eu des changements
au Congrès américain et que cette aide
si elle devait
s'installer perdurer dans le temps elle
pourrait être mise en cause ça ce serait
important là aussi
oui bien sûr vous savez le voyage de
président zinski aux États-Unis avait un
seul but c'était de montrer le courage
ukrainien que et le besoin en arme en
tout cas et en soutient
américain parce que c'est le prix le
plus important et puis le soutien
occidental
à la résidence par rapport à l'agression
russe mais mais ces chiffres sont plus
du tout à jour s'il date du 1er juin
2022 vous disiez si on faisait le compte
au 1er juin au 1er janvier 2023 serait
plus du tout les mêmes et puis notamment
lorsqu'on parle de la France il faut
parler aussi de l'engagement européen
parce que la France bien sûr vous savez
bien cotise de façon très importante à
tout ce qui est engagement européen
merci beaucoup général Patrick dute
merci d'avoir été à nos côtés pour
décrypter évidemment ces chiffres et ces
annonces